Yeah, this is Dr. Connors. We are going to be talking about the book Line Brain that you're downloading, so I hope this is a blessing to you.
In this book we're going to go over some complicated things maybe, some things that maybe you already know about.
We're going to get into some details on what's actually happening in your brain when you have Line.
So understand this book is titled Line Brain but it can be with any possible Line Co-infection or it can be with any possible biotoxin.
Anything that's going on that's causing an inflammatory state in your brain.
So we have patients that come in that I'm quite positive that they have Line and test them and it's something completely different, some other parasite infection in their brain.
And H. Pylori which is the same family as line as far as the burgundorphy, the gram-negative bacteria, but it can be something else as well.
So even a heavy metal toxicity in the brain could cause everything that we're talking about in this book.
So even though the book is titled Line Brain I could do using the same cover, change line to anything throughout the entire text of the book.
And it could be called Keybo Brain or it could be called anything else. So I actually going to do that with Keybo Brain because that's so prevalent in my practice.
So when we're looking at what's going on with Lyme disease in the brain we're really talking about Phase 3 autoimmune Lyme.
So if you haven't discovered that so far you'll learn that in the first chapter of this book.
If you've downloaded my other books on Lyme you've already know this stuff so I apologize for the review of that.
But in the first chapter of this book I dig into some other ways that Lyme and other pathogens hide in our body.
Instead of just going into cellular there's other things that they could do to hide.
Ultimately when any biotoxin is elicited in normal immune response over time your killer cells are trying to kill it.
But the biotoxin like Lyme is hiding within the cells or using another defense mechanism to ward off an attack.
And your B cells your TH2 response is trying to fire to find the pathogens so it can make antibodies against it.
And that's what you'd measure in a blood test, Lyme antibodies.
But if it can't find it to make antibodies against it there's where you get a false negative blood test.
Then it suppresses that your TH1 sides fires again to try to kill it while there's nothing that has antibodies against.
So this teeter totter of an event goes on for weeks and months, TH2, TH1 response, TH1, TH2, TH1, TH2 back and forth.
Pretty soon your TH2 cells can start making antibodies against your old tissue.
In the area where it's trying to kill the pathogen.
So if it's in your brain you're going to have a lot of antibodies to your brain and you're going to have issues.
Once you start making antibodies to your old tissue that's the definition of phase 3 Lyme.
It could be phase 3, each pyloriah could be phase 3, anything, what the antigen is.
So Lyme just happens to be the antigen in this person's autoimmune disease.
That's what's going to cause all sorts of symptoms.
You're going to have brain fog confusion, memory loss, any kind of brain issues that you can think of.
And understand that you have two, multiple parts of your brain.
We're talking about brain fog and memory loss, et cetera.
We're talking a mainly frontal lobe and some deep parts of the brain, the hippocampus and the big deline, such.
With severe memory loss it could be the temporal lobe.
But also if you have inflammation in your parietal lobe, the sensory cortex,
that's a person who can have fibromyalgia type symptoms.
They can have pain all over their bodies.
One day their arm is hurting so bad, it's just throbbing and they can't take it.
They can't stand it and the next day their arm doesn't hurt at all and it's the right foot that hurts.
It's just crazy, how can that happen?
Well, many people have attributed, well that's because the lime is moving around.
Well, that can be the case, but usually it's not local lime in the foot or in the arm.
It's an inflammation in the parietal lobe of the brain.
So whatever area of the map of the body that the parietal lobe is inflamed,
you're going to have symptoms in that part of the body.
We're talking about brain fog and things like that.
We have to understand those different lobes, the frontal lobe,
and what it does, the platy, the really the executive of the brain.
In this book we talk mainly about that because that's a lot of people's symptoms.
Temporal lobe, the parietal lobe, the occipital lobe, the cerebellum.
The cerebellum, you get inflammation in there and you have antibodies made against cerebellar.
Cells, you end up with dizziness and it just loss of balance and runny into things.
Very, very common with lime patients.
Now you could measure antibodies, there's different tests that you could do.
This is a Syrex test that measures antibodies throughout the whole body.
It's called their array 5.
Their array 10 measures antibodies specifically just to the brain.
Here you can see the top one is parietal cell and myocardial peptides.
If you have antibodies to your heart, myelin proteins.
So you get antibodies to your myelin, sheath.
You're going to have demyelination and all sorts of problems.
Many people with chronic live and live brain are diagnosed with MS, ALS, etc.
Once you have antibodies to self tissues, now your immune system is going to kill
that which you have antibodies against first.
So any immune reaction, any immune stimulation, it's going to kill that which you have antibodies against.
So in the case of live brain, you're immune killer cells every time they fire.
Even if you have a common cold, you're going to destroy what you have antibodies against.
If you have antibodies against your own nervous system, this slide is a durod.
You can have dead, dreaded antibodies, nucleol, antibodies, violent sheath antibodies, antibodies to the ax on itself.
You're going to be in big trouble, you're going to have a lot of symptoms.
Your brain literally is going to be on fire.
So in this book I'm going to give you some solutions, what you can do to help with this.
First of all, you have to get rid of the antigen, so that's the biggest thing.
But then there's ways to calm down the inflammation, ways to calm down the inflammation of the brain.
And dumb, that's what you're going to read about in the later chapters of the book.
So I hope you enjoy it, and it's a blessing to you.
If you have any questions, make sure you contact our office.
Thanks very much.